[Music]
America's Got Talent judge Mel D says
she was forced to hide the real reason
behind her bruises she is hiding no more
Mel B now claims a yes her husband Kosta
that is what she's alleging this all
just came to light in a restraining
order that she filed and she describes
his alleged abuse in disturbing detail
Mel B is claiming the abuse followed a
pattern at the height of her successes
her husband of almost 10 years Stefan
Belafonte would quote beat me down to
let me know that he was in charge she
included photos as evidence this image
of her with a bandage on her face and
another from the UK X Factor where she
claims bruises are visible her timeline
of alleged physical abuse in this just
filed restraining order dates back to
November of 2007 the day after her
finale on Dancing with the Stars
she claims Stefan placed both of his
hands around her neck began choking her
and slammed her down on the floor in
July of 2012 as a judge on the
Australian x-factor she says a planned
segment with Usher sent Belafonte into a
jealous rage
she claims Belafonte punched her with a
closed fist and split her lip then more
abuse claims the following month in
August of 2012 she was part of the Spice
Girls performance at the closing
ceremony of the London Olympics the
following day she says Belafonte quote
punched me in the face with a closed
fist at the time Mel B posted this photo
of an injury and claimed that she fell
while running and seven-inch heels now
in the court paper she says that Stefan
forced her to post the falling story as
a cover-up also in the filing Mel
alleges Belafonte got their nanny
pregnant and demanded that she get an
abortion we reached out to Belafonte who
did not respond to our request for
comment he did however tell a paparazzo
he felt like he was being set up
everybody wished my beautiful daughter a
happy birthday on Sunday he Instagram
this upbeat video with his stepdaughter
and their daughter as for Mel she's
focusing on work she walked the red
carpet for America's Got Talent
seven days after filing for divorce
she did not talk to reporters but
definitely had the support of her fellow
judges she's at what we call a trooper
you know she's holding up very difficult
I've spoken to her but I'm impressed
with her we're a family and we all take
care of each other we'll have each
other's backs and having that kind of
unconditional support right now I'm sure
means the world to her MLB is focused on
her personal life now but America's Got
Talent does return on May 30th on NBC
tough story yes
[Music]
you